bonjour les filles je suis ravie vous
retrouver dans ma cuisine stéphanie
delbene ça sert désormais d'internet
pour vendre des ustensiles de cuisine
crise sanitaire oblige elle ne se rend
plus aux domiciles de ses clientes et
bauchi mots on va faire comme prévu je
vous ai envoyé la recette hier soir les
roses de pommes feuilletée on va
utiliser le moule machine avec cette
recette elle va pouvoir présenter de
nouveaux produits à ses clientes
habituelles
elle a adapté son processus de vente en
filmant sa démonstration en direct qui
bossent au début j'ai cru que ça allait
être très très très compliqué je je je
n'imaginais peut-être même pas que mon
métier pourrait continuer et même mêmes
grandir pendant pendant cette phase de
confinement et c'est étonnamment ce qui
s'est quand même passé
moi j'ai un avantage sur vous les filles
ce que c'est que vous avez l'ancien aux
pattes qui est top
mais qui était pas gradué et ça marche
elle a augmenté son chiffre d'affaires
de plus de 50 % en un an
les participantes sont en moyenne cinq
ou six par rendez-vous tournant
numérique de la vente à domicile
convient parfaitement aux clientes de se
voir et de cuisiner ensemble s'adapte le
covin et on a dû changer nos habitudes
mais comme ça chacun chez soi la manche
et en bourgogne c'est pas nul à chatou
on est loin mais on est quand même très
moyen d'apprécier un super moment
ensemble chacun faire ce soir sont
belles et je vote pour les tiennes celle
etienne les plus jolies en un an
l'entreprise a multiplié par trois son
nombre de conseillère c'est le cas aussi
de cette société spécialisée dans les
produits cosmétiques à base de miel près
de châteauroux
cette chef d'entreprise a organisé des
formations pour ses nouvelles recrues
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui elle pilote
une formation aux réseaux sociaux
digitaux sont toujours à utiliser dans
une continuité de nouveaux vendeurs ont
rejoint la société en 2020 sans compter
les anciens ils ont changé leur méthode
de vente comme sabine le maire pour qui
ça n'a pas été facile
premier atelier ambitieux cheval de dire
la souffrance pour moi parce que j'avais
pas j'aime pas avoir mon image photo il
ya qu'à voir vidéo en train d'accoucher
je me suis va être génial parce que j'ai
pas d'une solution aller plus loin et
sortir de sa zone de confort avec là je
peux vous dire que depuis un an je l
espère retrouver les ventes à domicile
elles viennent de reprendre
progressivement en france comme ici dans
l'indre ou distancer masques sont de
rigueur mais produit chouchou le masque
nourrissant qui sont très très bon chef
il a pourri la base de cognac l'acacia
et j'essaye de maintenir au maximum le
présentiel
mais ça qu'avec avec le virus je suis
quand même aussi beaucoup développée sur
instagram et c'est avec malgré tout j'ai
réussi maintenant avoir ma petite
clientèle sur installer les clientes
pourront compter sur les deux
la vente directe n'est pas morte mais
sera dorénavant complété par la vente
sur internet